muchas mamás
soy decir ya de 97 años su nombre árabe
es abdel qader pero prefiere usar su
nombre kurdo lleva 4 años en méxico
donde llegó después de haber pasado un
tiempo en irak cuando escapó de siria
tras padecer la violencia de la guerra
este cristiano chocolate me pasó un
disparo en mi pecho esta fue razón más
fuerte que mi familia me obligó que
salir del país porque ya estaba muy pero
dura mi vida aunque dejé mi estudio qué
lástima pero este fue obligado a salvar
mi vida para guardar más de mansour o
aprendió español en aguascalientes y
luego pudo seguir sus estudios de
administración de empresas en monterrey
con un sistema y un idioma ajenos lo que
lo hizo muy difícil
la vía para que pudiera continuar su
formación fue la organización proyecto
hub esa que contacta a sirios exiliados
en situación humanitaria crítica y les
ofrece una oportunidad de méxico tenemos
convenio actualmente con 20
universidades alrededor de todo el país
hemos recibido a 21 estudiantes en total
de estos 21 4 se han graduado y este
diciembre de 2021 regresan también una
camada si no me equivoco como seis
estudiantes más
sabella apoya a los jóvenes no sólo en
sus estudios también los acompaña en su
regularización migratoria y en el
proceso de adaptación al país
nos enseñó un paquete de cultura de
idioma de comida de gente de
comunicación detrás de todo muchísimo
este es concepto de la gente de la
cultura que me agregó muchas cosas
mientras estaba en mi primer año aquí en
aguascalientes aunque le encanta méxico
ya que está decidido a volver un día a
su país aportar la experiencia adquirida
y contribuir a la reconstrucción